vous savez que dijon est candidat pour
être capitale verte européenne et nous
voulons un peu marqué les esprits pour
dire à tout le monde que tous les
plastiques tous les mégots qu'on jette
dans cette avaloirs vont finir à la mer
pour nous la mer méditerranée car ils
vont cheminer à travers les rivières et
donc nous avons voulu pédagogiquement et
symboliquement dire aux gens attention à
ce que vous jetez mais d'autre part
techniquement nous avons mis en place
avec suez dans le nouveau contrat d'eau
un système particulier qui va capter
toutes les microparticules de plastique
et donc dijon sera la ville la plus
éloignée de la mer nous sommes la vie de
la plus éloignée de la mer mais la
première qui prend des dispositions
particulières pour éviter que les micros
plastique que l'on peut trouver dans nos
eaux usées on les retrouve jeter dans la
méditerranée